لحظات للتاريخ عاشها كل محبا للمنتخب
الارجنتيني وهو يرى افضل لاعب في العالم
بلا منازع يحمل الكاس الاغلى كاس العالم
ومن غيره البرغوث ليونيل ميسي الذي سطر
تاريخا جديدا باسمه كاسرا عقدته الازليه
ومنهيا صيام سته 36 عاما لمنتخب بلاده عن
تحقيق البطوله الابرز في عالم كره القدم
انتصر ليونيل واطلق الكثيرون على البطوله
العالميه المنتهيه لقب بطوله ميسي التي
حققها بعد فوزا مثير على فرنسا بركلات
الترجيح بعد تعادل ايجابي في اللقاء
بثلاثه اهدافها كسرى ميسي احسن المونديال
حمل الارجنتين على عاتقه فحمله زملائه
اللاعبون بقلوبهم لرفع الكاس سويا ولتاكسي
قطر والمنطقه العربيه مونديال التاريخ
سيبقى في ذهن ميسي وعشاق الكره 100 حتى
النهايه بعد نجاح تنظيمي ورياضي كبيرين
وفي ختام مونديال قطر 2022 وكم اعتدنا
نستعرض معكم بعض احصاءات وارقام للمره
الاخيره بعد انتصال الارجنتين على فرنسا
والتتويج بالمونديال للمره الثالثه ميسي
هو اللاعب الوحيد الذي فاز بالكره الذهبيه
كافضل لاعب في المونديال مرتين وتحديدا في
نسخه 2014
ومونديال 2020 اصبح ليونيل ميسي اللاعب
اللاتيني الاكثر تسجيلا في بطوله كاس
العالم وكوبا امريكا برصيد 26 هدفا ليتخطى
البرازيلي رونالدو الظاهره الفرنسي كيليان
مبابي هو الثاني لاعب يسجل ثلاثه اهداف
وهاتريك في نهائي كاس العالم بعد ضيوفري
هورس لاعب منتخب انجلترا في نهائي مونديال
في مباريات النهائي بالمونديال هدف في
نهائي مونديال 2018
وثلاثه اهداف في نهائي 20 22 ليصبح اللاعب
الاكثر تسجيلا في النهائيات قبل ان يتم
الرابعه والعشرين من عمره اخيرا وصل رصيده
اهداف البطوله الى 172 هدفا لتسجل رقما
قياسيا وتصبح نسخه مونديال 2022 الاكثر
تهديفا في تاريخ بطولات كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
من الدوحه ينظم
صباحك مبروك اهلا بك واضح من لبسك واضح
مبروك يا نايف ومباراه عظيمه مباراه
مجنونه كيف كان الحماس كيف كانت الاجواء
امس في مباراه النهائي
اهلا سهام طبعا انا ارتدي قميص البطل بغض
النظر عن اي امر اخر لكن بالفعل يعني امس
كانت المباراه حماسيه جدا وقد يكون يعني
السيناوي الذي حدث في نهايه المباراه
والتعادل اضحى يعني كثير من الحماس
والتفاعل في
داخل الملعب وخارج الملعب بالامس همم يعني
خلال همم طريقه همم الى الملعب شهاده يعني
الاف من الاشخاص يسوون باتجاه الملعب همم
يعني بالتاكيد ان العدد كان يفوق همم عدد
المدرجات 88,000 ولكن يعني خطا نجحت في ان
يكون هناك منطقه محاضره للملعب تتسع لكل
الجماهير لذلك من يملك تذكر وذهب الى داخل
الملعب ومن لا يملك تذكره كان في همم
بوليفارد الوسيل هناك كانت شاشات هناك
كانت همم احتفالات طبعا امتدت اشواط
الاضافيه ثم الى ضربات الجزاء وكان هناك
يعني امور ملفته ومور جميله يعني همم
وجماهير مثاليه يعني كانت الجماهير
الارجنتينيه تحيل المنتخب الفرنسي وايضا
حيه امبابه عندما تم اعلانه هداف
لبطوله كاس العالم في المقابل كانت
الجماهير الفرنسيه تحيي ميسي وتحيي
المنتخب الارجنتيني ولكن يعني اللقطه او
المشهد ال- ال- ال- المختلف عندما ما هو
ميسي بجانب كاس العالم وضع اصابع يده وقبل
كاس العالم في هذا المشهد كانت شاشات
الداخليه تعوض اللقطات وهاتف واهتز الملعب
باهتافات الجمهور
الارجنتيني هناك يعني همم طريقه في همم
تحفيز ميسي استخدم الجمهور الارجنتيني عبر
وتر خليجي
سنعود اليك في تويتر
خليجي نذهب الى ضيوفنا الذين حضروا هنا
الى الاستوديو لنعيش اجواء اليوم الاخير
وما حصل يوم امس منير رحومه الصحفي
الرياضي وعبد الجواد رشوان اهلا بكما منير
الكره غداره كما هي الحياه في الدقائق
الاخيره وفي اللحظات الاخيره تحصل
المفاجاه تقييمك اليوم امس صباح الخير
صباح الخير
متعه كره القدم هي هذه الكره المجنونه
يعني بالامس يعني عيشنا نهائي مجنون لم
يسبق ان عشنا مثل هذه المتعه الكرويه في
مباراه النهائيه مباراه ممتعه تقريبا يعني
في كل المراحل هذا سواء في الوقت الاصلي
او حتى في الوقت الاضافي وراء كانت
الترجيح طبعا هي كانت الحظ شاهدنا طبعا
اداء متفاوت يعني خلال المباراه بين
المنتخب الذي لم نعرفه في بدايه الشوط
الاول وخلال كامل الشوط الاول في الصفحه
الديك الفرنسي في الدقيقه 80 وكانت صيحه
يعني قويه اسمعت الكل في العالم واعاده
بقوه وحققه تعادل مثير جدا اعتقد المباراه
او فات بوعودها كنهائي مميز يحمل همم نجم
واسطوره كرويه كبيره وهو ليونيل ميسي ونجم
بارز وقارب بقوه وهو همم
[ضحك]
المباراه قدمت الكثير من الرسائل
الايجابيه العالم تقريبا حتى يعني انصار
الكوره الفرنسيه وانصار كريستيانو رونالدو
فرحه لتتويش ميسي
فائز به الكره الذهبيه سبع مرات اقتحس
فلوس لجميع الجوائز الكره الذهبيه الحذاء
الذهبيه وكاس العالم ماذا تقول لميسي في
وداع مرحبا جديد صباح الخير
مباراه الامس وين وصلنا نعم بالفعل هو
انصاف لكره القدم في الدرجه الاولى فوز
امتع الجميع مباراه من العيار الثقيل ملعب
يسجل رقم تاريخي باستضافه عدد المباريات
ميسي كان لابد ان يتوج بهذا اللقب انصاف
لجميع الزملاءه اللي عاثروا فتره الكرويه
يعني ليس من المعقول ان كريستيانو رونالدو
على سبيل المثال ينافس ميسي على مدى سنوات
طويله ولا يطور لكريستيانو ولا ميسي لذلك
هو انصاف لميسي هي مباراه رائعه جدا
المباركه كانت ميسي وحارس الارجنتين في
مواجهه وحارس المنتخب الفرنسي اهداف رائعه
ثقيله طبعا لابد من ذكرها لان ميسي اليوم
هو يخرج من كاس العالم رافعا اللقب الجميع
ي بس عن بطوله كاس العالم والكاس الاغلى
التي رفعها مارادونا عام 86 الى يوم الامس
من اليوم بدايه مرحله جديده الجميع عرض
الصوره التي يحمل فيها همم مارادونا الكره
ويسلمها لكن امام بامبي مستقبل طويل وعريض
هو اصغر لاعب يلعب في مبارته نهائيتين هو
اصغر لاعب تاريخيا يسجل في مباراه
النهائيه
سجل عام 66 من القرن الماضي لم يتمكن اي
لاعب لم يكن برازيلي ارجنتيني الماني
انجليزي بتحطيم هذا الهاتريك
ولديه المستقبل رائع وكبيره هو انتصار
للكره العربيه السعوديه تمكنت كما يتحدث
الكثير وهو هاشتاج اصبح اليوم السعوديه هي
سوبر البطل هي الوحيده التي تتمكنت من
الحلقه الهزيمه بالبطل
كاس العالم ميسي حقق كل جوائز من القبرص
على كل جائزه كمان في عيد ميلاده انه انت
ربحت الارجنتين لك
وهذا ملخص سريع المشوار ميسي مع الارجنتين
في خمس نسخ بالمونديال من اول ظهور في كاس
العالم 2006 وحتى رقصته الاخيره في
البطوله
[موسيقى]
طيب منير لطالما كانت عدم ااا فوز ميسي
بكاس العالم مثيره للجدل وكثير من الناس
لم يصنفوك اعظم لاعب في العالم بسبب عدم
حصول على كاس العالم هل حسم الموضوع امس
وصار من اعظم رياضي العالم بعد ابلي
ومراتو بالتاكيد هي منظومه طبعا الجوائز
اكتملت بالامس هو اللقب الكبير واللقب
الاهم في مسيره اي لاعب يعني المقارنه بين
مارادونا وميسي كانت تقوم على كاس العالم
لان يعني في النهايه مارادونا قاده هذا
الجيل وهذا همم
الشعب الذي متعطش كثيرا لكره القدم من شعب
الارجنتيني قاده الى التتويج بلقب كاس
العالم فكان الانتظار طويلا لكن في
النهايه ميسي اسطوره كبيره لا تقل قيمه
ونجوميه عن ما حققه طبعا مارادونا بل
بالعكس القاب كثيره هناك العديد من
الجوائز تضاف الى السجل التاريخي لميسي
تعتقد ان اليوم نتكلم عن اسطوره حقيقيه
بكل فخر اليوم ياكله الجمهور الارجنتيني
نملك اسطوره كرويه لا تقل امكانيات على اي
اساطير كره القدم التي مرت في التاريخ الى
مارادونا لكن يمكن ان يكون ميسي اسطوره
يعني مميزات حديثه في هذا العصر
اليوم هل ركلات الترجيح ظلمت المنتخب
الفرنسي في النهايه ام انه لا كانت اصوات
رقصه التانجو هي الطاغي على اصوات الديوك
خلال الساعتين كل حياديه
هلا ركلات الترجيح هي تعتمد بالاساس على
راي قائد الفريق ان كان ارجنتينيا وعلى
راي المدرب بمن اللاعب القادم ليس من
الضروره ان يكون هداف الفريق قادر على
تفجير ركله الجزاء خاصه انه
اخضع لضغوطات كبيره على ارضيه الملعب على
الجماهير التي تصفق يعني عندما يتم اخذ
القرعه واختيار المرمى ليس عن عبس هذا
الشيء لان الجماهير القابعه خلف المرمى
تقوم اما بمسانده حارس المرمى او يعني رفع
مستويات الى الاعلى او انزالها الى الاسفل
لذلك ركلات الترجيحيه تعتمد على الخبره
تعتمد على الهدوء على طريقه التنفيذ كما
نلاحظ يعني هو ميسي قام بتنفيذ ركلات
الجزاء لا تصدق ولا ترد لا يمكن لاي حارس
في الكره الارضيه ان يصطاد الكره لكن سقط
طبعا فرنسا
مستحق بين الفريقين غضب كريم بنزيما ما
عدم اشتراك ولو شارك هل كان سيحدث فرقا
خصوصا انه كان هداف وحيد هو البامبي الى
فرنسا
لا هو يعني تاثير كبير همم معنويا وفنيا
اللاعب جيروم بالامس كان غائب تماما عن
يعني خط الهجوم وهذا ما اثر يعني كثيرا في
اداء المنتخب الفرنسي وحتى بالنسبه لي
ركلات الجزاء همم شاهدنا من سدد ركلات
الجزاء بالنسبه للمنتخب الفرنسي اغلبهم
اللاعبين الاحتياط الذين يعني دخلوا في
النهايه لا يملكون خبره هذه المواجهات
الكبرى لا لو كان مثلا جريزمان لو كان
اجيرو لو كان بنزيما لو كان ديمبلي
موجودين خلال يعني اكيد بالتاكيد يعني
فهذا واضح ان يعني في النهايه الكوره اردت
انصاف المنتخب الارجنتيني بخير ميسي
ومستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه وهذه الساعه
الموندياليه
التاريخ
ستبقى لمده طويله في ادهان عشاق كره القدم
البطوله الاولى من نوعها التي تقام في
الشرق الاوسط في الشهرين نوفمبر وادي
السمبر بعدين تعود عشاق الكره الكره
وتالقا عربيا لافتا تمثل بوصول المغرب
للمربع الذهبي وتحقيق المركز الرابع فيما
حقق المنتخبان السعودي والتونسي انتصارين
للتاريخ امام الارجنتين وفرنسا مونديال 20
22 شاهد لاول مره قياده تحكيميه نسائيه
لمباريات وتحديدا في مباراه المانيا
وكوستاريكا التي قادتها الفرنسيه ستيفاني
برابر لمساعده البرازيليه
والمكسيكيه كارين دياز البطوله الحاليه
لاكبر نجوم العالم خلال السنوات الماضيه
وعلى راسها ليونيل ميسي ورونالدو وسواريز
ولوكا مودريتش اما اعظم لحظات مونديال قطر
على الاطلاق فهي لحظه تتويج ميسي
والارجنتين بكاس العالم بعد مسيره تاريخيه
لميسي تعود اليك نايف من الدوحه يسعد صباح
مجددا نايف همم بعد شهر من الاحتفالات شهر
من الاقتضاء السكاني وكل
يا عبر العالم حضره الى قطر لحضور
المباريات اليوم شو راح يصير هل بلشتوا
تحسوا من منذ هذا الصباح انه الامور عادت
الى طبيعتها ما قبل شهر من اليوم
سته اهداف الامور كثيرا وقد تكون بدا
يومنا اليوم بمغادره البطل يعني قبل قبل
ساعه غاده متحافله المنتخب الارجنتيني همم
مقر سكنها باتجاه
حمد الدولي ستنتقل بطائره خاصه الى بيقولو
اسرائيل هناك تنتظرها الجماهير وبالتالي
ستغادر همم الجماهير اتباعا يعني همم هناك
ازدحام كبير وهمم عدم وجود مقاعد اللي على
في حالات المغادره من مطار الدوحه اليوم
وهمم غدا ايضا ولكن بعيني يعني همم على
ذكر السعوديه والمنتخب السعودي دائما كان
هناك سؤال يتودد للجماهير الارجنتينيه
ويرز ميسي في الامس لما كنت اجي لقاءات مع
الجماهير الارجنتينيه همم احد المشجعين
وبالتاكيد هو والجديده ويعلم اني سعودي
اول ما همم بدات المقابله معه همم سالني
هو ويل ميسي ولم يمهلني
رد عليه هو وضع اصبعه على قلبه وقال هنا
وجلب لنا النجمه الثالثه ايضا كان هناك
احتفالات من بعض الفرنسيه
رغم الخساره انهم قالوا انه نحن سعيدين ان
اا انها ذهبت
لميسي من ضمن التجاوب الجميله التي
رصدناها خلال طوال الشهر وهي التي لن
تتكافا نهائيا في اي كاس عالم اخر هي قدره
على التنقل بين اكثر من مباراه وهذه
اخذناها نحن اعلاميين وايضا كجماهير
تستطيع عظمته ان تحضروا المباراه الاولى
وتحضر المباراه الثانيه وتحضرون المباراه
الثالثه بكل سهوله ايضا دعيني يتحدث عن
نقطه مهمه واعتقد انها ستغير المفاهيم لدى
المنظمين في البطولات المقبله نعلم ان قطر
منعت همم مبيعات الكحول في الملاعب هذا
الامساها كثيره في الحد من المشاكل ومن
الاشتباكات ومن احداث الشغل وايضا من
الاصابات بين الجماهير كم سنتواجدت في
مسيرات الجماهير نحو المترو او نحو منطقه
البوليفار كانت الامور تسيب بثلاثه كان
العناصر التنظيم عددهم قليل بكثير بسبب
هذا الامر ايضا امس الاحتفالات التي كانت
في البوليفارد هذه اول مره في تاريخ كاس
العالم ان تقوم الدوله المستضيفه
بالاحتفال همم الفريق البطل شاهدنا
الاحتفال والمسيره صارت بشكل مميز بسبب
هذا الامر همم
فقطين استطاعت الحصول على نجمه الثالثه
بعد فوزها للمره الثالثه في تاريخها
بمونديال كاس العالم فخلاص هيحطها سودانيه
عندك في البيت شكرا شكرا
كان ودي ان ميسي يوقع كان ودي ان ميسي
يوقع عليها لكن ما صوت فرصه شكرا نايف
يعطيك العافيه شكرا جزيلا منير عبد الجواد
كلمه اخيره في مونديال قطر وفي هذا الوداع
الاسطوري
كاس عالم
اول مره في دوله عربيه قطر شرفت العرب
واعتقد انها رفعت سقف يعني تنظيم كاس
العالم الى اعلى ما يمكن في اعتقاده بطوله
بلمسه عربيه مميزه البشنه الذي طبعا
ارتداه ميسي سوف يبقى عالقا في تاريخ كره
القدم العالميه اعتقد انجاز بطبعه عربي
فكل الشكر لدوله قطر وكل الشكر للمنتخبات
العربيه التي ايضا قدمت مستويات جيده وعلى
راسها المنتخب المغربي
من العيار الثقيل بالفعل القطار اثبت انها
قادره على هذا التنظيم رغم التحديات
الكبيره او وجدت نسخه مختلفه عن نسخه في
التاريخ بشكل كامل انتخابات قدمت مستويات
رائعه جدا امتعونا باللقاءات ام تعونا
بالمباريات بالاهداف بالارقام بالارقام
القياسيه والعديد من الامور طبعا شكرا لك
سهام شكرا لك نادين شهر كامل وانتم على
مواصله عجله
المونديال ودورانها شكرا طبعا لمخرجنا
الرائع الوسام
وكل المقدمات الجميله والاخبار المتعلقه
بالرياض وخصوصا عمرو عبد السلام شكرا
جزيلا لكم
همم عندي كنزه بتوقيع ميسي صارت من نصيبك
يعني
شكرا شكرا شكرا